as we wind up for the last big Sports
weekend of the year that traffic is a
signal of just how many people making
their way to Las Vegas as really their
ultimate destination recent reports show
High Travel numbers and a positive
economic Outlook Sasha Loftus joins us
live from the Las Vegas Strip with the
latest Sasha
ladies and Brian it can be a pain to
deal with so much traffic but this
traffic is actually crucial to our local
economy local agencies actually say the
tourist traffic we've been seeing is
setting records
it's fabulous
a fast start to another jam-packed
weekend Southern Nevada has a sloth of
events on tap from the Pac-12
championship game at Allegiant Friday to
NFR and another Raiders game Sunday
people are once again descending in
droves on our city it's really changed a
lot I haven't been here in like five
years this week Harry Reid International
released its latest travel numbers with
October setting a record of more than 5
million passengers served
the roads also packed with parts of the
15 and streets near the Thomas and Mack
taken over but it is so good to
again and coming from a small tourist
town in Florida we had the same sort of
issues many are still talking about our
economic rebound after the covid-19
pandemic though unlv's latest economic
Outlook study has shown a slight stall
in our initial post covet boom gaming
gains are still strong with wins for
September surpassing 1 billion some we
spoke with say it was their first time
back here in a while it seems like it's
quadrupled the size that it was 20 years
ago and while Las Vegas completely blew
what they expected out of the water they
say they're happy to soak up everything
we have to offer it's a lot of fun
now Reid International says those high
traffic volumes they've been seeing
aren't just tourists but locals as well
which means the parking fills up pretty
quickly they say they're starting a new
project in the beginning of next year to
add more parking options in both
terminals reporting live tonight Sasha
Loftus 8 News Now